jeff bezos often gets a bad rep as the
evil bald dude behind
amazon people often accuse him of
reaping the benefits of his laborers
work
suggesting that he doesn't deserve the
wealth he has accumulated
though jeff bezos may not put in as many
hours as his employees today
he has taken on extreme financial risks
in the past before making it big
and at many points throughout his
journey things were looking quite bleak
so here's the story of how jeff bezos
lost 90
of his world in less than two years
[Music]
starting off throughout the 1980s and
early 1990s
computer technology was rapidly
advancing which allowed for lower entry
prices
and faster adoption than ever before
this combined with the launch of the
first couple of generations of windows
made using computers a practical task
for the average person
as a result computer and internet usage
was growing in the thousands of percent
per year in fact this would be the main
reason that jeff bezos would quit his
cushy job at a hedge fund
and decide to start amazon he describes
that internet usage was growing at 2 300
per year while he was over here at a
hedge fund
banging his head against a wall trying
to get 10 or 20
annual growth figures with that jeff
bezos would start an online bookstore
named amazon in the year 1994. this
would turn out to be really good
and really bad at the same time you see
it wasn't just jeff bezos that was
anxious to enter the online game
but so were investors throughout the
1980s
and early 1990s the boomer generation of
the time
often wrote off computers as another fad
that would die off sooner
or later however bill gates would
destroy this notion
in 1995 bill gates would become the
richest person
in the world at age of just 40 years old
more importantly bill gates rise had
little to do with speculation
and guessing microsoft was strongly
profitable from the day they went public
and over the years they had simply grown
their dominance and profits
so bill gates had become the richest
person in the world
using tech legitimately aside from this
several other successful tech companies
were starting to pop out around the same
time
like cisco aol and oracle
but just because these were so
successful didn't mean that the internet
and computer space were an automatic
gold mine
despite that though the people who had
missed out on the historic growth of
these companies
were obviously not very happy many of
these guys
whether large hedge fund managers or
your everyday millionaires
were determined to catch the next
microsoft and this
is where things start to go downhill or
i guess
uphill microsoft enjoyed strong stock
growth because they had strong control
of the market
and even stronger financials but this
wasn't exactly the case with most
companies entering the tech scene
including amazon these up and coming
tech companies boosted large revenues
and user growth
year after year however their bottom
line was often heavily in the red
venture capitalists and retail investors
didn't really care though
this might sound irresponsible and it is
but there was some reason behind the
madness it's not like investors were
putting all their money into one tech
startup and hoping for it to blow up
rather venture capitalists were of
course hedging their bets
pouring money into hundreds of tech
companies knowing full well that most of
these companies would go nowhere
that didn't matter though they just
needed one of their hundreds of
investments to become the next microsoft
as that would more than make up for all
of your losses
considering this these investors would
beat up the stock of essentially all the
tech companies they could find
meanwhile jeff bezos thought that it was
a good idea to take amazon public
in 1997. though they were facing big
competition from barnes noble at the
time
amazon had extremely promising
statistics in just a year preceding
their ipo
amazon managed to grow their user base
five and a half times
from 180 000 customers at the end of
to 1 million customers in october of
1997.
concurrently the revenues were growing
even faster
in 1996 they enjoyed 15.7 million in
revenue
this exploded to 148 million in 1997
and by the end of 1998 they reached a
whopping 610
million evidently amazon easily had the
growth numbers to beat a quote-unquote
next microsoft which left investors
eating them up
starting with an initial price of 18 per
share
amazon stock would skyrocket between
1997 and
2000. in fact their stock would grow so
fast
that amazon would complete three stock
splits within just a one and a half year
time frame
the first stock split was a two to one
split in june of 1998
this would be followed by a three to one
split at the start of 1999
and later that same year amazon would
complete another two to one stock split
in september of 1999.
with all of these stock splits each
original share of amazon would be worth
12 shares
even with these splits though amazon
would support a share price of 92.31
in january of 1999. if amazon had never
split their shares
that would be the same as a share price
of one thousand one hundred seven
dollars
and 72 cents let's keep in mind that
just
one and a half years before this amazon
was worth 18
a share i tried using a return rate
calculator on this growth
and the calculator straight up told me
please use reasonable numbers
so i did the math myself and amazon's
return on investment over those one and
a half years
comes out to six thousand fifty four
percent or about a fourteen hundred
percent return
annually to put this in perspective
let's take a look at tesla stock
you guys might think tesla stock has
gone crazy since november of 2019
and it has but to match the growth of
amazon stock over those one and a half
years
tesla would have to reach a share price
of three thousand seven hundred dollars
by may of 2021
or a pre-split price of eighteen
thousand five hundred dollars
clearly amazon no doubt experienced some
above average returns throughout the
late 90s
despite their success on wall street
though amazon was juggling a variety of
significant issues
for starters they were going through a
legal mess
in 1997 barnes noble would sue amazon
for claiming that they were the largest
bookstore
in the world barnes and noble argued
that though amazon might have the
largest catalog of books in the world
they didn't have any retail locations so
they weren't really a bookstore
at all in retaliation amazon would
accuse barnes noble
of tax evasion in states where they had
stores
according to legal experts this move
from amazon was quote
brilliant looking back though this is
quite ironic
as amazon would end up being a company
that is infamous for undercutting taxes
anyways as neither company really wanted
to deal with these accusations
they would come to a settlement later
that year but
just as this drama came to an end
walmart would decide to sue amazon in
1998.
walmart would accuse amazon of
recruiting former walmart employees to
uncover trade secrets
and this lawsuit would drag on for a
couple of years
in the meantime large amounts of capital
was still flowing into amazon
which eased the financial burden of
growing the company while dealing with
these lawsuits
however all of this would change at the
turn of the millennium
no one really knows what caused the
dotcom bubble to burst starting in early
2000s
but here are some factors that likely
played a role
first of all there were a lot of early
investors in the dotcom hype companies
i mean it wasn't that hard to be early
you didn't have to call the company's
growth
10 or 15 years before it actually
happened you just had to bet some money
on the internet a few years before
everyone else
and you would be up tens of times on
your money
considering this these early investors
likely started to take profits
at that point they had already caught
the next microsoft
sure the business side of the company
wasn't quite there in most cases
but the stock growth was already there
and oftentimes
it was even greater than that of oracle
and cisco and the other classic tech
companies with strong fundamentals
thus it made sense to take some profits
off the table
generally this should have little effect
on the overall stock growth of the
company
as if a company truly has strong
fundamentals new buyers should flood in
as early investors get out but as we
know though
none of these evaluations were built off
of a strong foundation
something else that may have caused the
downfall is that the majority of people
feeling fomo in late 1990s
had already got in thus there was no one
left to buy a stock for even higher
prices
the combination of these two factors and
likely several other driving forces
led us into a series of negative
feedback loops as the stocks of tech
companies started to dip
instead of new buyers looking to buy the
dip early investors were starting to get
more fearful
maybe it was time for them to lock in
some profits as well
this in turn introduced greater selling
pressure into the market
and the pattern repeated a couple of
times until we entered a full-fledged
sell-off
consequently amazon stock would crumble
from their peak of 106.69
in december of 1999 to 5.97 in september
of 2001.
considering that virtually all of jeff
bezos wealth was tied up with amazon
stock
just as it is today as well his net
worth would get slashed from a little
over 10 billion
at the peak of the bubble to 1.2 billion
at the bottom
now of course this means that he never
lost the title of billionaire throughout
the fiasco
and most of us would be thrilled to have
just 1 billion dollars
however i'm also quite confident in
saying that most of us would feel
awful if we tumbled from over 10 billion
dollars down to just 1 billion within 2
years
despite this terrible turn of events
jeff bezos would continue trying to make
amazon profitable
and he would be successful in the fourth
quarter of 2001
at the same time he also worked on
diversifying the business by launching
aws
which to this day accounts for the
majority of amazon's profits
slowly over the years that followed
investors would realize that though
amazon was likely very overvalued during
the dotcom bubble
the company did actually have strong
fundamentals and a bright future
consequently nearly a decade later this
positive outlook would allow amazon to
cross its dot-com high during late 2009
and since then amazon has been on a roar
growing past three thousand dollars a
share from just six dollars in 2001
allowing jeff bezos to be one of the
richest men in the world
what do you guys think about amazon's
valuation today do you guys think it's
overvalued or do you think there's
plenty of growth left
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
amazon's rough ride through the dotcom
bubble
well and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one